-You were an understudy
for a bit?
-I was an understudy.
Yes, which I highly recommend.
I was an understudy for a play
called "Gemini," 1980.
Danny Aiello was in it, a fe
other people, Bob Picardo,
who went on to do "Star Wars,"
Reed Birney, Jonathan Hadary
and I'll keep going.
But, anyway, 1980.
I was an understudy.
There were like six roles,
I'm going to say --
three men, three women.
I understudied -- Four men -
I understudied
the three young guys.
And I had to learn, I mean
three different support --
And they're onstage, so it's
like blue, red, yellow,
I mean, the whole script is.
I had it all down. I was ready
Picardo, I think,
was so sick one night,
at 5 to 8:00,
he was puking into a bucket.
They were holding the bucket
I'm in the costume, ready to go,
and he goes, "I can do it.
And he goes. And he goes.
So, it's five months
of never going on.
So, 8:00 comes.
They all go on once again.
So I slip out the back door,
go down to the apartment,
my little one room on
23rd Street.
And I'm watching
the Rangers hockey game.
One night, the phone rings
It's the stage manager.
"What are you doing?"
"Well, Rangers are up 2-1.
-Yeah.
-"I'll see you tomorrow."
And now I had to
say "good night" to him
at 10:00 every night.
-So you had to
stay all the way through.
-Yeah, I had to
stay all the way through
and watch other people do it
-You mentioned the Rangers
I know you to be a sports fan,
and I'm always curious
about this Broadway softball
league that happens,
where different shows --
-Do you have one
with the TV thing?
-Every now and then, yeah.
Every now and then, we
go out and get --
Steve, is it fair to say
we don't do great?
Our stage manager is doing this,
and he's pretty arrogant,
so that's bad, yeah,
if he's willing to do this
[ Cheers and applause ]
-He's part of the problem.
-Yeah.
-See, he was probably a good
high-school athlete.
-Yeah.
-Still thinks he is.
-I think he -- [ Laughs ]
-Which is the problem, because
once you get into your 30s
and you're out there playing
that ridiculous, stupid game
called slow-pitch
softball, which is...
and these guys doing that,
you are --
It's just a matter of whethe
you tear an ACL in your knee
whether you pop an Achilles,
or whether you rupture
a hamstring.
It's all going to happen,
because you're going
to be going around pretendin
you're 18 and you're not.
You're 32
and now you're face-down.
-I played in
a charity softball game,
and the third time I came up
the charity coach --
not a regular coach, just one of
the other people of the charity.
He goes, "Hey,
you want to bunt this time?"
I was like, "Buddy, was it tha
bad my first two times up?
I mean, I can't, like, somebod
doing the big swing,
and then I just
lay down a bunt."
I'm like,
"I'd rather just go home."
-Get your first base.
-We were talking -- I always
like asking people
who do Broadway shows.
You know, do people -- 'Caus
Keri Russell was just here
and said, you know, they playe
a song during her production
of "Burn This," and somebody
just audibly said,
"I don't like this song"
in the audience.
Have you gotten vocal feedback
like that from people
who sort of have -- There'
a sense of entitlement,
I think, at Broadway shows
-Yeah. I mean, we get a lot of
"oohs" and "ahhs."
I mean, there's a lot of
power and moving things.
And we had a guy
the other night.
I don't know why.
He was dead asleep.
-Oh, yeah.
-Dead asleep.
He was in his 90s, so God bles
him for even showing up.
-Yeah. I mean, to get out of the
house, that's already --
-And he was out of the house
-That's a triumph.
-It literally was this...
[ Cheers and applause ]
I had a guy -- In the '80s
I was doing off-Broadway,
and I had a guy sleeping
in the front row.
And I had some anger issues.
So, I get over there
and I can see it.
I'm going,
"I can't even believe it."
She says, "I love you."
And I go...
[ Sighs ]
"I love you, too!"
[ Cheers and applause ]
He was like, "Boom!"
-Hey, congratulations
on the show.
Congratulations
on the nomination.
Always a pleasure to see you
Jeff Daniels, everybody.